hello everyone I was sorry about not
posting any videos yesterday this flew
really got the better of me it's making
it really impossible for me to work but
the Isle of Man tournament finished
yesterday Magnus Carlsen took the win
and well I mean if you've made a very
funny remark about his victory he said
that you could really see the influence
of larceny by watching his games and
well that's funny because his
girlfriend's last name is Larson but as
that tournament is over we can now get
back to some real chess games this game
was played in 1948 it's played between
Rashid Najma Dino and wladis McKenna's
and as Rishikesh Medina well he got all
his Soviet master norms so the Soviets
picked out another Soviet master to test
him so he could be granted his Soviet
master notice also we missed master
title and while he was supposed to play
against listen and he prepared against
to play against listen but in the last
moment they chose what asthma chemistry
replace him between E and chess master
who was later who later became an
international master and also an
honorary Grand Master so he had very
little time to prepare for McKenna's and
well this is one of the games they
played in their match it's the aliens
defense and Rashida's medina has the
white pieces so let's see this
interesting game Rashid goes e4 Wien
like to have 6e five nights to d5 and
now see for the two pawns attack we have
like to be six and Rashid goes for c5
the Lasker variation we have Knight back
to d5 and now Bishop to c4 and we have
easy six defending the knight Knight to
c3 and here we have the move d6 this is
also called the McKenna's gambit as
Wallace McKenna's is the person who
brought it into play and it's it results
in a very sharp game for both black and
white we have Knight captures and v5e
capture 75 and Bishop captures and e5 so
black is given up upon for rapid
development and here he plays c6
if he would if he were to capture this
point for example he captures an e5 rush
it plays Queen to b3
oh sorry come to f3 and this is
threatening checkmate on f7 and also
threatening this pawn on b7 so instead
after Bishop captures on d5 c6 is played
and well here Rashida goes for it he
plays Bishop captures on f7 with check
we have King captures on f7 and now pawn
takes C takes on d6 and okay Rashid has
8 points
McKenna's has 5 points so it's really he
mechanics is up a piece but those
central pawns are really strong we have
Queen to d8 and Rashid plays Queen to e2
now defending the e5 pawn we have c5
making room for the night and we have
nice to f3 and here mechanics plays
Bishop captures and d6 so a counter
sacrifice and this is a pretty good move
very resourceful
if Rashid captures this bishop for
example he capture some b6 Queen
captures any - King captures an e2
lavrov to e8 with check King to b1 and
for example Bishop to g4 and this is
perfectly fine for black like it doesn't
really have any problems here
so after this Bishop captures on d6 move
Rashid plays Knight to g5 check and well
here we have King to g6 and now if
Rashid captures captures this Bishop
captures on d6 then Queen captures Queen
with check and then while McKenna's
captures this night and g5 but Rashi
plays a queen to d3 with Czech offering
this night on g5 so King captures on g5
is played and now Queen captures on d6
is played and well here here is a pretty
bad move from Hakeem as he plays Queen
to d8 and well he thinks that his King
is extremely vulnerable now here on g5
but his King was actually ok there white
is threatening this d4 push but after
King to h5 black can hold this for
example Knight to c6
d4 with check King to h5 and now Queen
captures on c5 or queen e7 this is
perfectly perfectly fine for black
but after Queen captures on d6 he played
Queen to d8 and now we have d4 with
check came to a5 and now G for King goes
to e4 you don't want to capture the pawn
to allow a move like rook to g1 check we
have Queen captures on c5 and now rook
their fate you can't really capture this
d4 pawn with the Queen if Queen captures
on d5 on the force or this loses the
Queen f3 check out King to d3 Queen to
a3 check Kings the c4 now Queen b3 check
King c5 and our Bishop to e3 and well
this loses the Queen so I throw Queen
captures on c5 rook to f8 is played
we have castles by Rasheed with ideas of
rook to e1 check so came to f3 is played
and now h3 not allowing that Bishop to
capture on g4 b6 is played attacking the
Queen
we have Quintus III check King goes back
to e4 and the hero she plays Queen to c4
and in this position a lot of McKenna's
resigned the game as there is no defense
whatsoever against the rook to e1 check
and one after rook to e1 checking has to
go to f3 and rook to e3 is checkmate but
whatever black plays this is
undefendable he can't prolong it with
some moves for example Bishop captures
on g4 or maybe work f3 but this all
results in a pretty quick mate
for example rook e1 check rook to e3
rock characters III king f4 rook back do
you wanna check King f3 and queen to e 2
this is checkmate but of course that the
Queen to see for once Mika has resigned
the game and well Rashid want this
beautiful miniature this is the this is
the 22nd move and well although he did
produce a brilliant victory and there
were a lot more wins for Rashid but the
match was drawn and Rashid was not
granted his Soviet master title he
became a Soviet master two years after
after this game was played so yeah it
was a very nice game at least I think so
I do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Wellington Martinez Zechariah
Finlay Thomas Joe
and Edward LeMonde for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon